mes chers amis nous ne devenons pas les
républicains sans raison profonde
il y a dans ce geste une réponse à
l'époque nous devenons les républicains
parce que nous ressentons la gravité du
moment
nous demandons où en est notre triptyque
chéri liberté égalité fraternité
où en est la république aujourd'hui que
nous arrive-t-il la liberté c'est la
liberté de pensée la liberté de dire son
opinion est il toujours possible de dire
son opinion
la liberté de la presse existe-t-elle
toujours depuis le 7 janvier 2015 et la
liberté d'entreprendre
écoutez nos entrepreneurs en colère les
pigeons les tondus les moutons écoutez
les artisans les commerçants les
professions intermédiaires qui subissent
les pratiques du rsi ils vous diront où
en est la liberté d'entreprendre et la
liberté d'aller et venir
c'est une vérité connue que nous
jouissons nous ne lui sont pas de la
même liberté sur tout le territoire
c'est une vérité accablante parce
qu'elle signifie qu'il n'y a pas de
république si la sécurité qui est le
premier des services publics n'est pas
assuré partout et pour tous il nous
reste la liberté de voter voir
attention vous l'avez vu comme moi la
majorité parle d'instaurer le vote
obligatoire avec des pénalités
financières pour les abstentionnistes
encore des pénalités financières
c'est une manie une obsession on est en
train de préparer d'inventer un impôt
sur l'abstention
voter est un droit c'est un devoir ce
n'est pas une obligation
voter est une liberté protéger la et
l'égalité ou en illégalité qu'en moins
de la moitié des ménages supportent la
totalité de l'impôt sur le revenu
on dit que l'impôt sur le revenu et
l'impôt républicain par excellence
eh bien il est devenu profondément
injuste que reste-t-il de la propriété
lorsque l'état prélève la moitié de la
richesse produite et l'égalité entre nos
territoires nous semblons sur le point
d'oublier voire d'abandonner notre pays
rural nos campagnes nos paysans peut-on
parler d'égalité
lorsque des millions de nos concitoyens
ne parviennent pas à trouver un logement
un emploi et où en est la fameuse
inversion de la courbe du chômage
enfin la fraternité je ne vois pas la
france apaisée où ce enseignera la
fraternité si l'école républicaine
renonce à la neutralité qui est son
devoir le plus sacré si elle devient la
proie d'une idéologie insidieuse mais
évidente qui divise au lieu de réunir
qui abaisse au lieu d'élever voyez le
triste sort qui est fait à l'histoire on
la remplace par des commémorations
d'innombrables commémoration ou la
connaissance cède la place à l'idéologie
ou le récit du passé ressemble à une
mise au pas des consciences une amnésie
bavarde est en train de prendre le
pouvoir
et que dire de la laïcité qu'est devenu
notre laïcité républicaine
c'est tout cela qu'il faut défendre et
ardemment c'est pour cela que nous
devenons les républicains nul ne prétend
que tous les républicains sont réunis
dans notre mouvement mais nous tous qui
sommes ici nous sommes particulièrement
inquiet de l'avenir de notre république
nous sommes convaincus de la nécessité
de la protéger et nous sommes
particulièrement déterminés à la
défendre
c'est pour cela que nous voulons être
plus fort et donc plus nombreux c'est
pour cela que nous devenons les
républicains pour ouvrir le mouvement
pour accueillir des nouveaux membres
nous sommes un grand mouvement politique
mes chers amis
sheikh nicolas sarkozy nous sommes
d'ores et déjà le plus grand mouvement
politique de france
c'est cela que signifie le passage aux
républicains que le moment est grave
qu'il faut revenir à l'essentiel
notre bien le plus précieux le préserver
notre bien commun le fortifier
c'est notre patrimoine politique notre
devoir est de le protéger de le faire
vivre de le léguer à nos enfants
comme nos parents l'ont fait avec nous
auparavant
mes chers amis pour être digne de la
mémoire de nos aïeux
il faut être digne du souvenir de nos
enfants alors oui oui oui cent fois oui
pour que vive la république vive les
républicains